my take has always been that competition
brings out
mean spiritness in people even if they
maybe
try to be spiritual and and they're well
educated they know
right from wrong do you think sometimes
that that be when any
community becomes something sought after
to be a part of whatever it is whether
it's quilting
i'm sure there's some mean quilters oh
yeah
or my squares are better than yours
exactly
a competition sets in and then even
though we want to evolve out of their
our egos and not be
caught up in that but that it's just
natural do you think that's part of it
i think it's definitely natural i think
what makes the huban community different
than maybe other communities
is that even if someone is caught up in
competitiveness
on some level they are trying not to be
and some of they know oh wow like this
doesn't feel right
you know what there's a lot of other
communities where the competitiveness is
just has
it has free reign it's like nobody's
even trying to not be competitive or to
be
kind or no one is trying to be different
they just you know the
the competitiveness and the
mean-spiritedness is part of it and it's
just accepted
where the hooping community that might
arise but even in the very person that
is sparking it
you know you feel there's that internal
struggle and eventually they will get
over it
and it'll be it'll you know like i said
earlier it'll kind of
smooth out so i think that's what makes
it really different is there's a little
extra it seems to be an extra level of
consciousness around it and um and a
willingness to grow through that and to
not be that way
and there's also an extraordinary
resiliency
because people who are hoopers they have
to go through this whole process of
coming out
as a hooper and for still for the
average person it's a little bit like
what like you love that you know like
how can that be something legitimate you
know
and so when you as a person go through
something where
you love something so much that you know
people are going to ridicule
immediately and you have to stand in the
face of that and move through that like
that creates a strength of spirit
that you know is is really beautiful and
i think that's very that can be very
singular for the hoop community anything
to add because you've been in hollywood
and
competition is is revered well what i
wanted to say is and it's in response to
what anna said i think is
what i think the film is really about is
finding something and
why i think a lot of people can relate
to it you know you might not be
interested in hooping
but you're interested in something and
you may not have
committed yourself to it and it might be
scary and you might think people
might not think it's the coolest thing
in the world and you're
scared of making a living and but i saw
that the hoopers that committed to it
that gave this crazy thing their all
that it gave back to them
you know they all were way better off at
the end
and it's just a very exciting story to
see to see that you know and i think it
really encourages people
to make a bigger commitment to the
things they really like and it's very
inspiring
even if they're crazy because it's you
know it's the crazy things
that end up making our civilization more
interesting
yeah hooping isn't boring
you